Você já parou para pensar que pode
existir um mineral capaz de reduzir o
risco de atos extremos contra a própria
vida em até 60%,
estabilizar o seu humor, proteger o seu
cérebro contra Alzheimer, ainda melhorar
sua memória e que a psiquiatria
convencional praticamente ignora essa
possibilidade. Pois é, meu amigo, minha
amiga, essa substância existe, está
disponível na natureza e pode estar
faltando seu organismo nesse exato
momento. E o mais perturbador, nenhuma
grande indústria farmacêutica tem
interesse em divulgar isso, porque não
dá para patentear o mineral. Nos
próximos minutos eu vou te mostrar
estudos publicados em 2024 e 25 que
estão virando o jogo no tratamento de
depressão, ansiedade até declínio
incognitivo. Se você sofre constelações
de humor, irritabilidade constante ou
aquela sensação de que sua mente não
funciona mais como antes, fique comigo
até o final desse vídeo, porque eu vou
compartilhar, vai mudar completamente
sua abordagem de saúde mental. Estamos
falando do lítio, mas calma, não é
aquele lítio pesadão que seu psiquiatra
receita e que te obriga a fazer exame de
sangue todo mês para ver se não tá
destruindo o seu rim ao tireoide. Esse é
o carbonato de lítio usado em doses que
variam de 300 a 900 mg por dia. O que
pouquíssimos médicos te contam é que
existe uma forma completamente diferente
desse mineral, que é o lítio orotato e
pode ser usado em microdosagens de
apenas 1 a 10 mg por dia, sem os efeitos
colaterais do carbonato. Para você ter
uma noção da diferença, é como comparar
um elefante com uma formiga. a
quantidade é até 400 vezes menor, mas os
benefícios pro cérebro continuam
impressionantes. Mas antes de mergulhar
nos estudos mais recentes, deixa eu te
contar uma história que faz fazer muito
sentido. Desde os anos 1990,
pesquisadores começaram a perceber algo
bem curioso. cidades e regiões onde a
água potável era naturalmente com níveis
mais altos de lítio e apresentavam taxas
de tentativas fatais contra a própria
vida, significativamente menores do que
regiões com água pobre em lítio. No
início, todo mundo achou que era
coincidência, mas aí foram feitos
estudos no Japão, na Áustria, nos
Estados Unidos, na Grécia, na Itália, em
Portugal. E sabe o que descobriram?
Todas as pesquisas apontavam pro mesmo
resultado. Quanto mais lítio na água,
menos pessoas cometendo esses atos
extremos. Uma metaanálise publicada no
British Journal of Psychiatry em 2020
reuniu dados de 113 milhões de pessoas
em 2678
regiões diferentes do mundo. E a
conclusão foi clara como água. O lítio
natural da água tem um efeito protetor
contra essas tragédias. E aqui eu tô
falando de quantidades ridículas, viu?
entre 3 e microg por Lro de água é
praticamente nada. Agora você deve estar
se perguntando, mas como é que uma
quantidade tão pequena de lítio pode
fazer tanta diferença? A resposta tá no
jeito que esse mineral trabalha no seu
cérebro. Diferente dos antidepressivos
convencionais que mexem só com
serotonina e dopamina, o lítio age em
múltiplas frentes ao mesmo tempo.
Primeiro ele bloqueia uma enzima chamada
GSK3 beta, que quando tá muito ativa
bagunça completamente a comunicação
entre os neurônios e aumenta aquelas
proteínas tal que se acumulam no cérebro
de quem tem Alzheimer. Segundo, ele
aumenta drasticamente os níveis de BDNF,
que é um tipo de fertilizante pro
cérebro, responsável por criar novos
neurônios e fortalecer conexões entre
eles. E terceiro, ele reduz inflamação
no sistema nervoso, que hoje a gente
sabe que é uma das principais causas de
depressão, ansiedade e declínio
cognitivo. E olha só que interessante,
em agosto de 2025 saiu um estudo
bombástico na revista Nature, conduzido
pela equipe de Harvard, que analisou
cérebros pósmem de pessoas com
Alzheimer, com comprometimento cognitivo
leve e de pessoas sem problemas
cognitivos. E sabe o que encontraram? As
pessoas com Alzheimer e comprometimento
cognitivo tinham níveis drasticamente
mais baixos de lítio no córtex
pré-frontal, justamente a área do
cérebro responsável pela memória e
tomada de decisões. Mais curioso ainda,
o lítio estava super concentrado nas
placas amiloides, aquelas proteínas que
se acumulam no cérebro de quem tem
Alzheimer. e a concentração só aumentava
conforme a doença progredia. Ou seja, o
corpo estava tentando usar todo o lítio
disponível para combater a doença, mas
não tinha lítio suficiente. E os
resultados práticos, deixa te contar
sobre o ensaio clínico publicado em
2024, que acompanhou pacientes com
comprometimento cognitivo leve por 13
anos. Os que tomaram lítium em doses
baixas, mantendo níveis sanguíneos entre
0,2 e 0,5 mimol por LRO, tiveram
resultados cognitivos muito superiores
ao longo de mais de uma década em
comparação com quem não tomou. Não
estamos falando de efeito placebo não,
viu? Os testes de influência verbal, por
exemplo, mostraram pontuações de 34 no
grupo do lítio contra apenas 11 no grupo
placebo. Então, o mini exame do estado
mental, aquele teste clássico de
cognição, ficou em 25 pontos no grupo
lítio contra 18 no placebo. São
diferenças brutais.
Agora, se você tá pensando, ah, mas isso
é só para quem tem problema grave de
memória ou tá começando com Alzheimer,
espera aí que tem mais. Um levantamento
de 2025 entrevistou 211 pessoas que
compram lítio orotato como suplemento
por conta própria. A dose mais comum era
de 10 mg de lítio alimentar por dia na
forma de aspartato ou orotato. E sabe
qual foi o resultado mais relatado?
Melhora na cognição, seguida de perto
por redução da ansiedade, estabilização
do humor. Mais da metade das pessoas com
depressão bipolar, que usaram doses
baixos de lítio por apenas seis semanas
tiveram remissão completa dos sintomas
de ansiedade. Eu tô falando de gente que
já tinha tentado de tudo e não conseguia
resultado. E aqui entra um ponto que me
deixa p da vida com a psiquiatria
convencional. Por que diabos isso não é
mais divulgado? Por que seu psiquiatra
não fala disso na consulta? A resposta é
simples e ao mesmo tempo revoltante. Não
tem dinheiro nisso. O lítio é um mineral
natural, não dá para patentear. Qualquer
empresa pode vender, não tem como uma
grande farmacêutica lucrar bilhões em
cima disso como lucra com
antidepressivos modernos. Então,
simplesmente finge que não existe. Além
disso, existe uma confusão enorme entre
o lítio medicamento, que todo mundo tem
medo por causa dos efeitos colaterais, e
o lítio micronutriente que estamos
discutindo aqui. São duas coisas
completamente diferentes, mas a
narrativa oficial não faz questão
nenhuma de esclarecer isso. Deixa eu ser
bem claro aqui, o lítio orotato em
baixas doses não é brincadeira e não é
para sair tomando por conta própria sem
critério nenhum. Você precisa entender
que mesmo em doses baixas, pessoas com
problemas renais ou de tireoide precisam
de acompanhamento. A grande diferença é
que nessas microdosagens os riscos são
infinitamente menores do que com
carbonato de lítio em doses
terapêuticas, mas ainda assim você tem
que saber o que tá fazendo. E aqui eu
vou te dar um panorama geral baseado no
que a literatura científica mais recente
recomenda. Agora, quando é que você
deveria considerar o uso de lítio
orotato? Baseado nos estudos mais
recentes e na experiência clínica de
médicos que trabalham com a visão
integrativa, os principais indicadores
são irritabilidade constante,
principalmente se você tem histórico
familiar de transtorno bipolar,
depressão, alcoolismo, oscilações de
humor que não respondem bem aos
antidepressivos tradicionais, ansiedade
que não melhora com terapia cognitiva ou
outros tratamentos, dificuldade de
concentração, neva mental, sensação de
que seu cérebro não funciona como
antigamente. mente histórico familiar de
Alzheimer ou sinais precoces de
comprometimento cognitivo, impulsividade
e dificuldade de controlar
comportamentos compulsivos. E claro, se
você tá naquela fase da vida em que
começa a esquecer onde deixou a chave,
esquece nomes de pessoas conhecidas ou
percebe que sua memória não é mais a
mesma, pode ser uma ferramenta de
prevenção poderosa. Um estudo publicado
no Psychiatric Times em 2024 menciona
que crianças com transtorno disruptivo
de desregulação do humor, aquelas que
têm explosões de raiva intensas e
frequentes, podem se beneficiar
imensamente doses baixas de lítio.
Adultos com transtorno de uso de álcool
também mostraram resultados
impressionantes. Num estudo antigo, mas
bem desenhado, 36 de 42 pacientes com
histórico de internação por alcoolismo
grave ficaram livres do álcool por 3 a
10 anos usando doses baixas de lítio.
Nenhum deles precisou de nova
internação. É um resultado que poucos
tratamentos conseguem atingir. E tem
mais um detalhe que deixa tudo ainda
mais interessante. O lítio age
sinergicamente com outras estratégias
nutricionais e de estilo de vida. Ele
melhora o transporte vitamina B12,
folato dentro da células cerebrais.
Então, se você já tá suplementando essas
vitaminas, o lítio potencializa o efeito
delas. Ele reduz marcadores
inflamatórios com protência reativa, cox
2, TNF alfa. Então, se você tá tratando
inflamação clônica com ômega-3,
curcumina ou outras estratégias
antiflamatórias, o lítio entra como
aliado poderoso e ele ainda ajuda a
reparar a barreira intestinal ao modular
GSK3 beta. O que significa que aquela
abordagem de curar o intestino para
curar o cérebro fica ainda mais eficaz
quando você adiciona o lítio na equação.
Agora deixa eu falar uma coisa que vai
contra a narrativa dominante, mas que é
sustentada por uma montanha de
evidências. A psiquiatria atual tá
completamente dominada por um modelo
farmacológico
pesado que não resolve a raiz do
problema. Eles te dão um ISRS, né, um
inibidor de recaptação seletiva de
serotonina. E se não funciona, te dão
outro. Se continua não funcionando, te
dou um terceiro. Aí adiciono um
estabilizador de humor, depois um
anciolítico e no final você tá tomando
cinco medicações diferentes, sentido
zero de libido, engordando 15 kg e ainda
assim não se sente bem. Enquanto isso,
estratégias nutricionais simples, como
corrigir deficiência em vitamina D,
otimizar magnésio, reduzir inflamação,
ajustar alimentação e adicionar
micronutrientes como lítio ficam
completamente ignoradas. Por quê? porque
não geram receita recorrente para as
farmacêuticas. É assim que o sistema
funciona, quer você goste ou não. E
olha, eu não estou dizendo que de
antidepressivos nunca funcionam, porque
todo mundo deveria parar com a medicação
e tomar só lítio. Longe, longe disso. O
que eu tô dizendo é que você precisa
conhecer todas as opções disponíveis,
incluindo aquelas que a medicina
ortodoxa finge que não existem. E o
lítio microdasagens é uma dessas
ferramentas que ficou esquecida,
ignorada, apagada do radar, não porque
não funciona, mas porque não gera lucro
suficiente. Pensa comigo, se amanhã
todos os psiquiatras do Brasil
começassem a prescrever litiorotata em
doses baixas pros pacientes com
depressão resistente, ansiedade crônica
e risco de demência, quanto dinheiro a
indústria farmacêutica perderia? Quantas
caixas a menos de antidepressivo de
terceira geração seriam vendidas?
Quantos pacientes deixariam de precisar
de múltiplas medicações? A resposta é:
bilhões de dólares. E é exatamente por
isso que você não vê propaganda disso na
TV, não vê matéria no jornal, não vê
campanha de conscientização. O sistema
não foi feito para te curar, meu amigo.
Foi feito para te manter dependente. Mas
a boa notícia é que você não precisa
esperar o sistema mudar para tomar as
redes da sua saúde mental. A informação
tá aí, os estudos existem, as
ferramentas estão disponíveis e olha,
não é só sobre lítio, não. Dentro de uma
visão integrativa de verdade, você olha
para tudo. Inflamação crônica, disbiose
intestinal, deficiências nutricionais,
toxinas ambientais, estresse crônico,
qualidade do sono, exposição à luz
solar, prática de exercício físico. O
lítio entra com uma peça do
quebra-cabeça, mas não é a única. A
diferença é que ninguém te conta isso no
consultório tradicional. te dá uma
receita de antidepressivo, mandam você
voltar daqui 3s meses e é isso. Não
perguntam se você tá dormindo bem, não
perguntam como é que tá a alimentação,
não investigam suas deficiências de
vitaminas, não olham os seus marcadores
inflamatórios, tratam seu cérebro como
se ele estivesse isolado do resto do
corpo, o que é um absurdo. E para
finalizar, deixo te dar um exemplo
prático de como isso pode funcionar na
vida real. Imagina uma pessoa de 45 anos
com depressão leve, moderada, que já
tentou dois antidepressivos diferentes e
não teve resultado satisfatório. Tá
começando a ter lapso de memória, sente
que o raciocínio ficou mais lento, tem
irritabilidade frequente, tome mal. Numa
abordagem integrativa, você começaria
investigando marcadores inflamatórios,
vitamina D, B12, folato, magnésio,
função tiroidiana completa, cortisol ao
longo do dia e saúde intestinal. ao
mesmo tempo, corrigiria as deficiências
com suplementação adequada, otimizaria a
alimentação para reduzir inflamação,
ajustaria o ritmo cicadiano com
exposição à luz pela manhã, introduziria
atividade física regular e aí como
cereja do bolo, adicionaria lítioato em
dose baixa, tipo 5 mg de lítio elementar
por dia. Resultado, em questão de
semanas, essa pessoa começaria a
perceber melhora no humor, no sono, na
memória, na disposição. Não é mágica, é
ciência aplicada de forma inteligente.
Então, se você chegou até aqui,
provavelmente está se perguntando: "E
agora o que que eu faço com essa
informação?" Primeiro, entenda que você
não é refém do sistema. Segundo, busque
profissionais que entendam de abordagem
funcional integrativa, que olhem além da
receita fácil, investigem as causas
reais dos seus sintomas. Terceiro, leia,
estude, se informe. Os estudos que eu
citei aqui estão todos disponíveis. Eu
vou deixar aqui na descrição, no
primeiro comentário, estão publicado em
revistas científicas sérias. Você deve e
pode pesquisar por conta própria. E
quarto, não aceite o rótulo de depressão
resistente ou não tem mais o que fazer
se antes explorar todas as estratégias
que a medicina ortodoxa ignora. O ltio
orotato não é a cura para todos os
males, longe disso, mas é uma ferramenta
poderosa que deveria estar no arsenal
terapêutico de qualquer profissional
sério que trabalha com saúde mental. E o
fato de não estar mostra o quanto
estamos presos numa lógica de mercado
que coloca lucro acima do bem-estar das
pessoas. Mas você não precisa aceitar
isso. Você pode buscar algo melhor. E
esse algo melhor começa com
conhecimento, questionamento, coragem de
ir contra a narrativa dominante quando
ela claramente não tá servindo.
Saia do vídeo agora se você gosta de
ficar no superficial. Eu vou te contar
uma verdade inconveniente. O YouTube e o
conselho de medicina me limitam. Aqui eu
preciso simplificar, censurar dosagens,
omitir protocolos controversos. Na
comunidade fechada não tem filtro.
Compartilho os exatos protocolos que eu
uso na minha clínica. Casos de reversão
que parecem possíveis, combinações of
label que funcionam, fornecedores
confiáveis, interpretação avançada de
exames. É basicamente ter acesso ao meu
cérebro médico sem intermediários, lives
semanais respondendo perguntas, PDF com
47 protocolos exclusivos, grupo no
WhatsApp. Se você quer a visão funcional
real, sem simplificação para massas,
clique em seja membro. Não é para
curiosos, é para quem quer resultados.